So, hallo, ich bin am Start. Ist auch noch jemand schon da?
So, Banjo ist am Start, Poggers, Clani auch am Start, Lizard FTW, Power Planter, Stellzoys, jetzt kommen sie alle, jetzt kommen sie alle.
Oh, jetzt kommt schon der erste Sub.
Max Axel, Twitch Prime, Poggers, Alter.
Moment, mein Meme Board ist kaputt.
Jetzt gehts, ich hab es kaputt gemacht.
So, übrigens Leute, ich weiß doch, dass ich Big Brain Chat habe, deswegen muss ich euch schon was fragen.
Und zwar habt ihr eine Idee, weil ich warte noch mal kurz, bis noch ein bisschen mehr Leute am Start sind.
Omega Cackville, ich hab leider alle Emotes besetzt, sowohl bei FFZ als auch bei WTTV.
Hauptsache abgekürzt alles.
Die Musiklautstärke ist eigentlich ok.
Also Leute, ich hol euch noch was fragen und zwar habt ihr eine Idee, wie man das Ganze hier anschließt und zwar gehen wir mal auf Amazon und dann suchen wir mal einen USB Sata Adapter.
Also dann gucken wir mal, glaub den hab ich hier, genau habt ihr eine glorreiche Idee, wie man, ich mein das ist ein Adapter für USB für SSDs, da ist kein extra Strom dabei oder sonst was braucht man ja auch nicht.
So ist das gedacht, funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut.
Ist im Prinzip das, was ich aus China bestellt habe, nur in funktionierend, weil die, haben wir ja hier im Livestream ausprobiert, die USB Sata Adapter, die ich in China bestellt habe, die brechen da ein bei der Übertragung, die sacken, sacken richtig.
So, habt ihr eine glorreiche Idee, wie ich es jetzt schaffen kann, also ich hab eine Idee, aber die gefällt mir nicht so gut, dass ich von da, von dem Anschluss für die SSD, dass ich da einen SATA Kabel reinstecken kann,
weil, die Sache ist die, so wie das ist, kann ich das nicht an irgendeinen Festplattenwechselrahmen anschließen, die haben ja keinen Anschluss, sie haben ja nicht solche Anschlüsse.
Die haben einfach einen Anschluss für einen Strom und einmal und halt 2, 3, 4, 5 SATA Ports.
Ja, es gibt Verlängerungskabel, aber die passen nicht da dran.
Ja, das habe ich auch gedacht, der Verlängerung passt da nicht dran.
Zeige ich euch warum.
Hier, guck mal, das ist ein SATA Verlängerungskabel, mit dieser Seite, müsste man die ja eigentlich da dranstecken, das Problem ist,
erstens, du stößt, ich kann jetzt, kann man dieses Foto irgendwie mal so groß machen, dass man, du stößt hier gegen diese, gegen diesen Zacken, also du stößt,
mein, wie rum, wie rum kommt es denn überhaupt, so rum, äh, so rum, also das da, das da kommt, kommt quasi auf, auf, auf die, auf die Seite, dann,
also das hier ist eigentlich zwar so ausgehöhlt, dass es, das ist eigentlich so ausgehöhlt, dass das hier drüber passt, aber trotzdem sieht man, der Zacken geht über,
geht, geht hier oben drüber raus und auf der anderen Seite ist ja hier, seht ihr es ja, hier in der Mitte, hier in der Mitte ist ja Plastik
und hier in der Mitte müsste eigentlich die andere Seite rein, bloß dort wo Plastik ist, ist hier auch Plastik, das heißt, hier macht man Plastik auf Plastik und es passt nicht rein.
So, was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist, ich hab zum Glück noch eine andere, äh, eine andere Verlängerung da, ich hab hier, also ich hab hiervon ein paar da und ich hab davon ein paar da,
da sind nicht genau die, aber sehen so ähnlich aus, ja, ähm, deswegen hab ich jetzt mal anstatt am Adapter rumzuwursten an diesem Ding rumgewurstet, aber es kommt aufs gleiche raus,
und zwar hab ich jetzt folgendes gemacht, ich hab hier das, was übersteht abgebrochen, diesen, diesen, diesen spitzen Knubbel hab ich abgebrochen,
auf der einen Seite dann ist das flach, dann passt das, und auf der anderen Seite, auf der anderen Seite hab ich vom Kabel das Plastikding abgebrochen und glattgeschliffen,
ja was, glattgeschliffen, ich hab, ich hab's einfach abgebrochen und das was noch übrigbar weggeschmiergelt, ja, ähm, jetzt passt das, und das funktioniert auch,
aber, es ist jetzt irgendwie nicht schön, oder, es ist, also, ich mein, da, ich muss, ich muss quasi Adapter sowohl SATA-Kabel umbauen bzw. abschneiden,
oder, oder wegschmiergeln, dass es passt, es funktioniert, also ich hab's ausprobiert, ich mach jetzt hier das SATA-Kabel dann im Endeffekt dran,
mach's, äh, mach's an die Festplatte und, und die Festplatte kriegt Strom vom Netzteil, das funktioniert überhaupt kein Problem, ähm, aber schön ist es nicht,
hat irgendjemand von euch da eine andere, eine schönere Idee, schmitty2802twitchprime, dankeschön poggers,
also, ich kann ja, ich kann ja mit leben, dass das abgebrochen ist, ich dachte da gibt's vielleicht irgendwas fertiges,
ich dachte da gibt's irgendwas, irgendwas fertiges, dass ich einfach nur das falsche, den falschen Typ, den falschen Typ SATA-Kabel gekauft habe,
ich mein eigentlich, eigentlich bräuchte ich ein SATA-Kabel mit nem Stecker, das eben nicht diese Befestigungsdinger hat,
ich mein, so zum Erklären wofür das da ist, ne, ich hab ja immer noch nicht meinen Heimautomatisierungsserver wieder aufgebaut,
und bei der Gelegenheit hab ich mir gedacht, ich kann das jetzt ja mal endlich probieren, ich hab mir damals alle, alle möglichen Sachen bestellt,
ich hab mir hier beispielsweise diese, die ganzen 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarten bestellt, hier so, ne,
Mellanox-Halse-Dinger, das, sowas da, oder, oder, okay, ich hab mir ein paar 10 Gigabit-Karten bestellt,
bei der Gelegenheit wollte ich das jetzt mal ausprobieren, wie gut das funktioniert eben mit 10 Gigabit,
so, das heißt, ich mach da mein Heimautomatisierungszeug drauf, und, ja, Lightning-Style, genau, sowas.
Zeig mal den Wechselrahmen, den du benutzen willst, ja, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, also was ich aktuell zum testen verw...
oh, fuck, wie heißt denn das Ding?
Muss ich mal gucken, guck mal, ob ich das Ding finde, ne, ja, fuck, ne, sagt ihr, sagt ihr klar, wenn ich, wenn ich das,
ich glaub, ich finde das auf der Seite nicht, Moment, ja, so in der Richtung, so in der Richtung,
plus halt mit mehr, zeig das mal von hinten, zeig mal das Ding von hinten, ja, so, so ungefähr, ja, das stimmt jetzt,
das ist jetzt zwar komplett, viel zu groß, ja, aber hier sieht man es, hier sieht man es doch ganz schön,
ne, du hast hier unten, hast du einmal oder zweimal Strom-Connector, und dann hast du in der Mitte die SATA-Anschlüsse,
so, und um das da, um quasi hier eine Platte per USB anschließen zu können, brauchst du einen SATA auf USB,
das Problem ist, dass alle SATA auf USB immer Strom dabei haben, oder aber irgendeine andere Bauform,
dass es nicht, dass es nicht, nicht reinpasst, das heißt, ich muss hier einen Kabel anschließen,
dass ich das dann da reinstecken kann, wie gesagt, mit meinem abgeschnittenen und abgefallenen Kabel funktioniert das Ganze,
aber es ist nicht schön, deswegen hab ich gedacht, vielleicht hat irgendjemand eine glorreiche Idee,
wie man das, wie man das Ganze schöner machen konnte, muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Subs vergessen hab,
Eluminato subscribt, Poggers hab ich gar nicht gesehen, oder? Huge Sub.
So, ich hab auch den ganzen Chat jetzt nicht gelesen. YouTube hat mir letztens wieder Gartenstellens Video empfohlen,
man kommt ein neuer Teil, im Winter vielleicht.
Schön, dass du letztens halt so aktiv bist. Ja, finde ich auch. Es ist schön, dass ihr noch so viel am Start seid.
Ehrlich gesagt, ein Kabel in ein Kabel stecken, ja gut, was willst du sonst machen, ja?
Also hat von euch auch keiner irgendwie eine glorreiche Idee, ne? Das ist natürlich blöd.
Ich hab gedacht, wir haben absoluten Big Brain Chat heute, aber anscheinend, anscheinend sind noch nicht genug Leute subscribed,
dass der IQ weiter steigt. Vielleicht klappt das ja im Laufe des Streams noch.
Wir wissen ja, dass jeder Sub den Durchschnitts-IQ, sagen wir mal so um 5 Punkte steigt,
und vielleicht schaffen wir es ja heute, wenn noch ein paar Subs, dass die IQ so weit steigt,
dass wir eine Antwort darauf finden, wie ich diesen Adapter auf diese Backplane gestapselt kriege.
15 Uhr läuft mein Sub aus Top Poggers.
Letztens hat sich irgendjemand unter dem Video beschwert, ich glaube unter dem Windows-98-Video,
also unter dem da, so nach dem Motto, dass das irgendwie unerträglich wäre, dass ich so internetsprachemäßig rede.
Und da hab ich mir so gedacht, Moment, wo sind wir hier denn?
Könnte das sein, dass wir vielleicht im Internet sind? Nein, das kann nicht sein.
Mach mal auch Windows 2000 oder XP. XP wollte ich machen.
Windows 2000 ist glaube ich nicht so interessant.
Blob-Version Vista. Ey, das ist eine gute Idee, das schreib ich mir mal auf.
Doch, ich mach echt mal ein Video zu Windows Vista, weil da kann ich sozusagen das meistgehasste Windows
oder irgendwie sowas in Titel schreiben, da stehen die Leute drauf.
Der Bildschirmarbeiter schreibt, da kann mir grad nicht ganz folgen, weil das ist doch die Rückseite,
vorne kommen die Platten rein, die Rückseite wird ans Mainboard oder den Rate-Controller angesteckt.
Wieso willst du hinten eine USB-Platte anstecken? Tja, das ist die Frage, ne?
Das ist die Frage. Und wie so vieles ist die Antwort darauf Big Brain.
Also mein Mainboard hat bloß zwei SATA-Anschlüsse.
Und ich habe ein Gehäuse mit einer Backplane drin, das ist ein billiges Gehäuse, weil ich will das ja,
ich will mal gucken, ich wollte ja schon die ganze Zeit gucken, dass ich möglichst billig
einen 10 Gigabit NAS bauen kann, möglichst billig.
Das ist nicht unbedingt was zum Nachmachen, weil ich muss schon ein bisschen Kompromisse machen,
aber ich will es einfach mal ausprobieren.
Und mein Mainboard, also sprich das Mainboard, was ich habe, wo ich halt eine 10 Gigabit-Karte reinmachen kann,
hat selber nur zwei SATA-Anschlüsse.
Die zwei SATA-Anschlüsse werde ich verwenden für, einen SATA-Anschluss werde ich verwenden für die Systemplatte.
Und die anderen zwei Anschlüsse brauche ich halt noch für die Platten.
Oder wenn es sogar vier sind, wenn es sogar vier sind, muss ich das ja auch machen.
Deswegen muss ich mindestens eine Platte per USB anschließen.
Und deswegen brauche ich halt irgendwie SATA-USB auf SATA, allerdings nicht auf kompletten SATA-Stecker mit allem,
sondern halt nur auf SATA, normales SATA-Kabel, was ich dann in die Backplane stöpseln kann.
Funktionieren tut das, ich habe das ja mit dem abgefallten Kabel probiert.
W, falls W, zwei Monate, POG.
Dankeschön, POGgers.
Plus 20 IQ, nein, nein, nein, so einfach ist es nicht.
So einfach ist es nicht.
Plus 50, äh, plus 5, plus 5.
Ja, ich meine, sonst werden wir ja ab, sonst wird hier unser Kopf explodieren demnächst durch die ganzen Subs.
Da haben wir zu viel IQ.
Hadi, Stufe 1, abonniert drei Monate, Dankeschön, POGgers.
Oder Koggers, müsste man hier an der Stelle sagen, weil es dreht sich ja.
Was SATA-Controller einstecken?
Also, ich habe so einen USB auf SATA-Adapter gekauft, das Ding hier.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriege ich das SATA von hier an meine SATA-Backplane dran?
Die Backplane bzw. der Wechselrahmen für die Festplatten, der hat ja nur normale SATA-Anschlüsse.
Das heißt, ich muss von da irgendwie da rein.
Das ist nicht so einfach, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ein SATA-Hub, gibt es sowas? SATA-Hub? Was gibt es nicht? Es gibt SATA-Multiplexer.
Ähm, das wäre eine Option, ja.
Das Problem ist, sowas haben wir im letzten Stream sogar ausprobiert.
Allerdings haben mich da die Chinesen gescampt.
Ich habe was gekriegt, was nicht das kann, was draufsteht.
Deswegen habe ich mich jetzt, bevor ich jetzt nochmal AliExpress China-Kram bestelle, habe ich mich dafür entschieden, wir machen,
ich nehme den naheliegenden Anschluss, nämlich einfach USB.
Und ist auch kein Problem, weil die ganzen USB-Adapter, die man mittlerweile hat,
die unterstützen alle quasi SATA, also im Prinzip SCSI, über USB.
Das ist halt USB 3.0, ist das Standard.
Das ist hier diese UASP-Geschichte.
Das ist quasi SCSI-Kommandos über USB.
Das heißt, es macht eigentlich gar keinen großen Unterschied, ob man die Sachen jetzt per SATA oder per USB anschließt.
Die Frage ist nur, oder das Problem ist, wie kriege ich den Mist von hier?
Hier dran, das ist das echtste Problem.
So, der Eichler ist zwei Monate am Start, auf Stufe 1, Dankeschön, Pongas.
Mark Zuckerberg, der Gründer, ich sage das übrigens absichtlich so, das ist genauso wie ich auch Amazon sage.
Wobei, ich finde gerade Zuckerberg ist eine schöne Betonung.
Der Gründer von Facebook ist rot-grün-blind und hat deshalb als Facebook-Farbe blau gewählt.
Jetzt kommen hier die krassen Facts.
Was mache ich? Das frage ich mich auch.
Abonniert per Twitch Prime. Dankeschön, huge.
XellXS ist neu am Start. Moin.
So was, oh, wir haben schon die ersten...
Ja, so was, aber diese Adapter, ja, solche Adapter habe ich auch gefunden.
Aber, ähm, also diese Adapter haben halt alle kack Bewertungen.
Und wenn man sich ein paar Meinungen dazu anguckt, sind die halt crap.
Solche, diese Adapter sind halt eigentlich ganz gut.
Habe ich ja auch schon zwei Stück da, die funktionieren ja auch gut.
Die anderen Adapter sind halt Müll. Den gleichen habe ich auch schon gefunden.
Stripes 007, Stufe 1, drei Monate schon.
XellXS.
Selber Adapter bauen, ja, das ist richtig massive brain.
Warum kaufe ich so nicht einfach eine USB-PC-Karte im Server rein?
Weil der keinen Platz hat.
Der einzige PCIe Express Slot, den das Mainboard hat
Das ist das falsche
Gibt es das noch als B?
Der einzige PCIe Express Slot, den das Board hat
Der einzige PCIe Express Slot, den das Mainboard hat
Gehauen
Kehne, aber ehrlich gesagt siehts besser aus. Es sieht schon besser aus als aus meinem eigenen 3D-Drucker
Am Rosse, so was bescheuertes. Ich will ein ganz normales Gehäuse verwenden können. Guckst du das mal an
So und
Deswegen das ist eigentlich das beste Board für mein 10 Gigabit NAS. Rein von der technischen Spezifikation her
Das hat ein Dual, es hat einen Quad-Core, es hat PCI Express mit vier Lanes angebunden
Ich meine das hier unten ist zwar ein M2-Slot, aber ist kein Problem. Macht man halt von einem Adapter rein, wo ein PCI Express-Slot oben drauf ist
Das einzige, einzige Scheiße ist, dass es falsch rum ist. Es ist falsch rum. Es passt in kein Main, es passt in kein Gehäuse rein
Ja, das ist ein M2, aber das ist ein M2 mit vier PCI Express-Lanes. Kannst einen Adapter rein machen und dann kriegst du PCI Express raus
Das ist nicht das Problem, das funktioniert auch, aber es ist unten. Es ist unten und es passt damit in kein Gehäuse rein
Deswegen muss ich dieses Board verwenden
Übrigens hier hätte ich das gleiche Problem mit den zwei SATA-Anschlüssen gehabt. Deswegen verwende ich dieses Board. Das hat zwar nur
zwei PCI Express-Lanes in dem 16-fach-Slot, aber
das reicht halbwegs für eine 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte. Ich meine, ich kriege da zwar kein Maximum von 10 Gigabit durch, aber so
so 7
7 Gigabit kriege ich da ungefähr durch
So zwei Drittel ungefähr kriege ich da durch. Das reicht. Mehr geben die Platten ja eh nicht her
Das ist mein Problem
Und deswegen brauche ich irgendwas, wie ich noch mehr
SATA-Platten anschließen kann. Und die nächste Sache ist dann, welche SATA-Platten will ich mir überhaupt holen?
Weil
wenn man das hier mal, wenn man das hier mal filtert, Preis pro
Terabyte
Dann sind 8 Terabyte das, was am attraktivsten erscheint aktuell
170 Euro 8 Terabyte. Man muss aber dazu sagen, ich habe ja schon 13 Terabyte Platten
Allerdings
Wollte ich die, ich will, ich will, ich will ja eigentlich nur zwei, ich will es ja viel einfacher machen. Ich will ja keinen, keinen Rate 5 mal machen
Wie, wie bei dem anderen. Allerdings sind die
ein bisschen anderweitig
verplant. Ich würde gerne eine der 10 Terabyte Platten bei mir im Desktop Rechner machen, weil ich komme mit meinen 6 Terabyte
an die Grenze. Manchmal, wenn ich einfach lange, lange Sachen aufnehme, ja und da meine Downloads sind komplett auf der, auf der, auf der
Platte, weil wozu soll ich die auf die SSD speichern?
Die ganzen Videoaufnahmen und Zeug kommen immer direkt auf die Platte drauf. Das heißt, da würde ich gerne eine 10 Terabyte Platte in
mein Desktop Rechner machen.
Die von denen ich jetzt habe und die anderen beiden zusammen, die sind ja dann bloß noch 10 Terabyte groß
und ich hätte gerne schon ein bisschen mehr. Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt
ich könnte mal gucken, was beispielsweise größere Platten kosten, und es mir aufgefallen, der Preis explodiert.
Ich verstehe immer noch nicht, warum du an die Backplane
eine USB-Platte anstecken willst. Ich will nicht an die, ich will nicht an die Backplane USB-Platte anstöpseln. Ich möchte SATA,
also USB-SATA, also ein USB-SATA-Adapter an die Backplane anschließen, weil ich nicht genug SATA-Anschlüsse auf dem Mainboard habe. Ganz einfach.
Ich will keine USB-Platte an die Backplane anschließen, ich will einen zusätzlichen SATA-Anschluss.
Na doch, natürlich, doch, dadurch habe ich mehr Ports. Ich habe zwei SATA-Anschlüsse auf dem Mainboard
und ich habe intern noch mal zwei USB-3-Anschlüsse auf dem Mainboard drauf, wo ich einfach zwei USB-SATA-Adapter machen kann.
Und ich kaufe mir keine, eine USB-Platte kommt ja eh dran für Backup.
Natürlich habe ich mehr Ports.
Ich habe zwei SATA-Ports auf dem Mainboard
und noch mal zwei SATA-Ports über USB, wie? Nein, das willst du nicht skamasen vom Namen her ey, ETF, Alter.
ETF, Alter. Nee, deswegen will ich das. Das heißt, ich habe dann hier zwei Anschlüsse, ich habe hier zweimal SATA und ich habe hier zweimal SATA.
Ich habe so einen Aufstecker, der quasi hier reinkommt und da sind dann oben drauf direkt zwei USB-3-Ports.
Also ich habe dann quasi hier zweimal SATA und hier zweimal SATA.
Deswegen brauche ich dann einen SATA-Adapter, der einfach nur SATA-Kabel kann, wo das ordentlich dranpasst.
So und bei Festplatte habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht vielleicht die hier kaufen sollte.
Ich meine 320 Euro, das ist ein Preis von etwas über dem, was quasi die besten Preis-Leistungsplatten kosten.
So 2 Euro pro Terabyte ungefähr drüber, aber dafür 14 Terabyte und die sind aktuell im Vergleich zu dem, was halt danach kommt, relativ günstig.
Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einfach zwei Stück davon kaufen soll oder vielleicht sogar, vielleicht kaufe ich mir sogar drei, dass ich nur mit eins machen kann, ich weiß noch nicht genau.
AI, warum AI? Ich habe keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich weil AI cool ist. Brauchst du PCI Express 4? Nein, nein, nein, ich brauche PCI Express 2.
Also 4 kann das Ding gar nicht. Wenn das Ding PCI Express 4 hätte, wäre es auch kein Problem, weil die 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte würde dann ohne Probleme mit zwei Lanes volle Pulle laufen.
Ja, so sieht es aus. 14 Terabyte, oh mega null. Warum? Das ist so nice. Gut, dass es mittlerweile gibt.
Guck mal, warum ist das so günstig aktuell? Das fällt. Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist huge price fall. Ich glaube, den muss ich gleich mal bestellen.
So, also ich bestelle mir zwei erstmal und das werde ich dann so machen. Die 2 Terabyte Samsung SSD gibt Systemplatte und die 14 Terabyte Platte hier, die gibt Platte für Gäste.
Für alles, was nicht schnell sein muss, was nicht System ist, was nicht Container ist oder VM oder sonst was. Zum reinen Dampen Zeugs.
Und die 2. 14 Terabyte Platte, entweder mache ich einen RAID 1 draus, was den Vorteil hat, dass ich meine 10 Gigabit Lesegeschwindigkeit ein bisschen besser ausnutzen kann.
Oder aber ich mache es ganz primitiv, die eine Platte rein und die andere Platte einfach nur nachts für einmal Backup.
So, jetzt habe ich euch alles erzählt. Ach ja und ich habe mir überlegt, ich mache davon ein Video, wie ich das Ding zusammenbaue.
Ich mache ein Video davon, wie ich das Ding zusammenbaue und erzähle dann auch ein bisschen was zu einer Trash Fast Platte quasi.
Aber ich sage dann auch gleich dazu, dass es nicht unbedingt zum Nachbauen gedacht ist. Auch wenn ich denke, dass das Preis leistungsmäßig echt unschlagbar günstig ist für eine 10 Gigabit NAS, würde ich dich unbedingt empfehlen, nur auf das aller billigste, also nicht nur versuchen, um das billigste zu bauen.
Zum Beispiel ist das Gehäuse, das ich habe, das ist zwar eine 19 Zoll REC Gehäuse, aber der Wahnsinn ist es jetzt nicht. RAID 0? Nee, nee, RAID 1.
RAID 1 meine ich. RAID 1 ist auch schneller als eine einzelne Platte. Nicht im Schreiben, aber beim Lesen. Weil du mit RAID 1 von beiden Platten lesen kannst. Was du mit RAID 1 nicht machen kannst, ist Schreiben auf beide Platten schneller.
Aber lesen kannst du, weil ich meine es ist ja ganz logisch, die Lese Performance von dem RAID 0 und dem RAID 1 ist ungefähr das gleiche. Du kannst bei beiden parallel die Datei von zwei Datenträgern lesen.
Der hier nicht VM wäre. Also wenn ich überhaupt auf dieser Kiste eine VM laufen lasse, dann ist es KVM. Oh ich glaube ich habe übrigens die falsche Kategorie eingestellt. Hab ich Just Chatting oder hab ich Designs and Technology?
Just Chatting, ah ja ok sehr schön. Ja ich glaube dann bestelle ich mir zwei von Mindfactory. Warum hat Mindfactory eigentlich so ultrakrass schlechte Bewertungen? Ich habe mit denen eigentlich immer gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Wehe man hat Probleme und die sind offenbar Vorprogramm. Alter, too long didn't read. Was geht mit den Leuten ab? Braucht ihr euch die halbe Lebensgeschichte der Leute um eine Bewertung zum Job? Na doch warum nicht? Warum nicht? Vielleicht gibt es ja mehr Details.
Hab ich irgendwelche Subs übersehen? Muss ich mal kurz gucken. Du hast mit Mindfactory schlechte Erfahrungen. Warum? Also bisher hat alles wunderbar funktioniert. Aber ganz davon abgesehen, eigentlich ist es doch überhaupt kein Problem.
Weil wenn man Probleme mit Mindfactory hat, man kann doch, jetzt muss ich jetzt mal in Warenkorb sagen, bestellen zur Kasse und dann gucken wir mal. Guck mal die haben doch Paypal Checkout oder? Kann man nicht direkt mit Paypal?
Kann man nicht mit Paypal Checkout machen direkt? Weil wenn man mit Paypal oder Amazon Pay bezahlt, also wenn man über dieses Paypal Checkout und Amazon Pay bezahlt, doch als Gast.
Und dann? Weil dann kann ich doch eh sagen, hier ich hab nie was erhalten oder es ist kaputt. Ich hab mal so ein kaputtes Rack bekommen und da war die Glasscheibe vorne gebrochen.
Und der Shop hat sich nicht gerührt, mit wie es aussieht, mit zurückschicken bzw. mit ersetzen hat sich nicht gerührt. Da hab ich bei Paypal einfach so einen Konfliktlösungsfall aufgemacht und hab gesagt hier, ich hab jetzt die angeschrieben, melden sich nicht.
Und man kann ja so ein Konflikt-Schlichtungs-Dingsbums da bei Paypal machen und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass am letzten Tag, wo das ganze ausgelaufen wäre und Paypal sich darum gekümmert hat, haben sie sich gemeldet und haben gesagt, ey ich krieg's Geld wieder, aber ich soll das Rack wenn's geht wegschmeißen, weil sie sind zu teuer das zurückzuschicken.
Hast du studiert oder eine Ausbildung? Ich hab eine Ausbildung gemacht, hatte 4 RX 5700, die defekt waren bei Mindfactory, bin dann in den Laden meines Vertrauens gegangen und hab mir ein Nvidia gekauft.
Hier, das ist halt echt Pech da. So, wir gucken jetzt ein bisschen Videos, weil heute ist Sonntagmorgen, eigentlich wollen wir aufwachen. Mit der Musik los. Eigentlich wollen wir aufwachen. So, mit was fangen wir an? Mit was fangen wir an?
Fangen wir mit der History of Speedrun Rainbow Road Mario Kart an. Fangen wir mit dem aktuellen Quake World Record Speedrun an. Oder fangen wir mit Spielen Leute immer noch World at War an.
Oder, ich hab noch ein paar mehr Sachen zur Auswahl, die hab ich aber noch nicht aufgemacht, hab ich in meinem Tablet. Dann haben wir noch zur Auswahl, haben wir noch zur Auswahl, das war's für mich, must buy, was die 3 must have features, wenn man sich den Staubsäure Roboter kauft.
Oder aber, was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl? Ich hab mir ein paar Videos aufgeschrieben, die wir gucken können. Oder Call of Duty lost its identity. Aber das ist schon von 2015.
Also, Rainbow. Quake World at War. Staubsauger. Quake. Okay, dann fangen wir zuerst damit an. Dann fangen wir zuerst damit an. Und weil das geht plus 11 Minuten, weil die anderen Videos sind ein bisschen länger, das geht 30 Minuten, das geht, fuck, Alter, 47 Minuten.
Was guckt mein Airfree Programming Tutorial von Jumbo? Du musst mir mal nen Link schicken.
Wir müssen eh ein Fortunate Video gucken pro Stream. Der Typ ist halt echt nice. Ich glaube, das hier ist eh fake, die Anzeige.
Das Problem ist, dass die Lobbies in World of War total verhexort sind. Beziehungsweise total viele Cheater Lobbies am Start sind. Es gibt wahrscheinlich keine normalen Lobbies mehr.
Mein erstes Call of Duty World at War war zwei. Weiß nicht wie euch, das war mein erstes Call of Duty World was ich gespielt habe war zwei.
Das Voice Acting Call of Duty 5 fand ich auch cool.
MP5 Beste. Das Ding war so, MP5 Juggernaut Extended Max. Oder Double Tap, Double Taps auch okay. MP40 Juggernaut Extended Max.
Der 5er Killstreak hat gesackt.
Denk mal in World of War waren die Hunde noch für 7er Killstreak.
Und die waren richtig gut aus Lack.
Hat einfach mal die Konsole ausgeschaltet der Host.
Wann lohnt es sich am meisten einen neuen PC zu kaufen? Also z.B. von Release neuer Hardware.
Er hat wahrscheinlich Hacker Lobby am Start.
Er geht wieder von vorne los. Sehr fair. Ich würde eher sagen die Hunde ist geklitscht.
Okay es ist nicht mehr spielbar.
Stimmt, das Cod hat ja diese nervigen Panzer.
Und die Panzer waren richtig dumm.
Ich weiß nicht warum sie die DLC Lobby suchen, aber die Hunde haben sie nicht.
Aber die Tanks waren richtig dumm in Cod 5.
Cod 5 hatte nicht alle, aber auf jeden Fall die besten Maps, aber die sind vorne mit dabei.
Das ist der andere Tank.
Das Ding heißt Gewehr.
Ich habe es auch nicht so mit englischer Aussprache, warum sollten die das da mit deutscher
Aussprache haben?
weil ich weiß, dass diese Jungs aufhören
und die Artillerie mich nur tötet
wirklich jetzt?
sind wir wirklich jetzt?
ich glaube, es ist toll, dass die meisten Waffen in diesem Spiel
alles nutzbar sind
ich wollte sagen, dass es nicht nur eine Waffe gibt, die die meisten benutzen
aber wenn ich es wiederhebe, denke ich, ja
jeder nutzt die MP40
aber in einem casualen Spiel wie dieses
siehst du meistens jede einzelne Waffe
oh, was macht dieser Typ jetzt?
ich nenne ihn Dogs und sie bekommen nicht einen einzelnen Töner
oh, die Waffe sackt
die sackt richtig
ey, die sackt
zumindest Run and Gun
technisch ist das coolste Crap-Waffe
gewesen
haha, der Nuptuber
da oben war doch einer
was guckst du da?
wir gucken gerade Fortunate
wir gucken eigentlich immer jeden Sonntag ein Video von ihm
macht einfach nice Videos
am besten war die russische Windmusik
in World at War
die russische Windmusik war beste
seitdem kenne ich auch die russische Nationalhymne
es geht ja noch weiter
Thompson Extended Max
auch übelst nice Map
Napalm Chunky
was ist das für eine Frage
Max, welche Waffe hast du
in Fortnite am besten gesuchtet?
am meisten gesuchtet?
Big Brain Frage
die Thompson war übelst nice
da konntest du auch aus der Hüfte schon draufsprayen
ja, I am Jinxed Loll
hättest du das ganze mal auf der Xbox gehabt
dann hättest du es jetzt backwards compatibility
mäßig spielen können
oh, Artillery geschreckt
ja, die Gegner sind auch absolute Bots
ja, das macht ja auch
Call of Duty, das ist das was ich auch bei Modern Warfare sage
Call of Duty macht
nur richtig Spaß public
wenn du ab und zu mal gegen
richtige Bobs spielst
nur da macht das Bock
wenn du permanent immer am Limit spielst
und gerade mal so
eine UAV hinkriegst
ist halt nicht so spaßig
habt ihr gesehen wie die Granate rausgeleckt ist
es war eine halbe Sekunde
das war eine halbe Sekunde
ja, das kommt dabei
Achtung
Our Artillery will shake them up
another kill
and that's game baby
31 and 5 on the 2 bar
after you play a game it's like
die Videos von ihm sind einfach nice
so it goes to a DLC map
and then it just lags out completely
and then you go to search for another game
and you join one in progress with like 2 people
holy crap, almost just got burnt to death
you are dead
you both would have been dead
but I don't know why you are sitting in a corner
I just want to go on the one
I call duty world at war
still people do play it
not a lot
and it is a pretty dead game
you cannot see
is this guy up here
hold that nade
he didn't hold that nade
he got dropped shoted
du bist auf Battlefield 3
müssen wir eigentlich mal wieder
they are just spawning up right now
just sitting in that building
and I do not like it
oh great, I am dead
how did I even survive the marder dome
what are you doing
what are you doing sitting in a corner
now he is on a rock head glitch
he is so weak dude
now he is dead
this was spread all over the wall
docks at start
Wauzis
Das war schon ein bisschen Grinch, irgendwie
Ich werde hier einen guten Doppel-Triple-Killer bekommen. Ich nehme einen, egal was. Du bist tot.
Ist hier noch jemand in dir? Wirklich?
Mein Junge, was machst du, wenn du in den Kreis postest?
Oh, jetzt werden sie aber weggesprayt, äh.
Wow, WTF. Alter, ist das gut.
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, was mein Score war. Wir waren einfach so nass. Oh, wow, das ist einfach so schrecklich, Mann.
Okay, Leute, hoffentlich habt ihr den Video genossen. Wenn ihr es genossen habt, dann gebt einen Like und abonniert, wenn ihr neu seid.
Die Videos von ihr mag ich echt. Also wie gesagt, ähm, guckt mal eben vorbei. Subscribart. Er macht schöne Videos. Nicht viel rumgemache, einfach Gameplay, um gut zu sein.
Wart ihr nicht für Inscope121 verantwortlich? Nein, nein, nein. Der Nico hat zwar bei uns früher mitgemacht, aber das hat er schon, für seinen Erfolg ist er schon selbstverantwortlich.
Das ist ja auch so der originale, für mich so der originale Lifestyle-YouTube-Channel. Das war ja der erste, der zumindest in Deutschland mit dem Kram so richtig angefangen hat. Und der war damals schon nicht immer so richtig glücklich mit so seriösem Kommentieren und Labern zu Games.
Der wollte schon immer so ein bisschen verrückteres Zeug machen und das hat jetzt ja auch ganz gut funktioniert. Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich hab jetzt lange nicht mehr geguckt. Das ist auch nicht unbedingt ein Content, der mich jetzt großartig anspricht.
Wieso heißt Max hier nicht Max? Oje, das hab ich schon öfters, öfters erklären müssen. Und zwar, äh, weil ich den Channel eigentlich zum Privat-Twitch-Gucken erstellt habe.
So, und jetzt hatten wir hier die Frage, ähm, Moin Max von Kiosk. Wann lohnt es sich am meisten einen neuen PC zu kaufen? Also zum Beispiel vor Release neue Hardware oder nach Release und dann die alte günstig oder eher in Zukunft investieren und die neue holen.
Ganz ehrlich, ähm, nach 20 Jahren PC gibt's dazu aus meiner Sicht eigentlich nur eine Antwort. Du solltest dir einen neuen PC holen, wenn dein Alter zu langsam ist. Und nicht warten. Es sei denn, es gibt irgendwas, was du mit dem aktuellen nicht machen kannst.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir jetzt irgendwas bauen will und ich brauche dazu unbedingt irgendwie, was weiß ich, ähm, mehr SATA-Anschlüsse oder was weiß ich, was die aktuellen Boards alle nicht haben oder irgendwie, der SATA-Anschluss ist blöd, die Boards haben masslich SATA-Anschlüsse mittlerweile.
Ich brauche irgendwie USB 3.2 oder USB 4 oder ich, ich brauche irgendwas, was das aktuelle nicht hergibt. Dann würde ich warten, ähm, aber ansonsten oder PCI 4 genau, falls man das brauchen soll. Also dann würde ich warten, da bleibt mir auch nichts anderes übrig. Aber ansonsten würde ich immer dann kaufen, wenn ich es brauche.
Und aktuell, so, und aktuell würde ich mir einen Ryzen Desktop zusammenbauen. Es gibt auch keinen Grund zu warten, weil es war eigentlich so gut, so gut wie seit langem nicht mehr preisleistungsmäßig sich ein gutes Desktop-System zusammen zu basteln.
Ähm, du brauchst ja den aktuellen Ryzen. Die Boards sind auch ganz gut, relativ teuer. Ähm, RAM ist günstig zurzeit. Festplatten haben wir gesehen, sind auch günstig zurzeit. Ähm, das einzige, was richtig teuer ist, sind Nvidia-Grafikkarten.
Aber ansonsten gibt es jetzt eigentlich keinen besseren Zeitpunkt, sich irgendwie einen neuen PC zu kaufen. Also ich würde das jetzt machen und ich würde es generell auch immer jetzt, jetzt holen.
Der Plan war eigentlich auf GTA 6 zu warten und das Setup darauf anzupassen, damit man das gut zocken kann in guter Grafik. Also sollte GTA irgendwann demnächst rauskommen, sag mal so innerhalb 1-2 Jahre, dann wirst du das auch auf dem PC gut spielen können, wenn du dir jetzt einen guten kaufst.
Aber es steht ja noch vollkommen in den Sternen, vor allem wenn PC-Release ist oder so. Oder?
Ja, das heißt du müsstest ja jetzt noch jahrelang warten. Ich würde aktuell trotzdem eine Nvidia-Karte kaufen, ja. Also wahrscheinlich würde ich mir wieder mal eine 2080 Ti holen, einfach, weil ich das schnellste habe, aber wahrscheinlich Preis-Leistungstechnik ist 1 oder 2 Stufen drunter, gegen eine 2070 Super oder eine 2080 Super, also wahrscheinlich deutlich sinnvoller.
Es gibt eine uralte Version von dem Meme-Board, gibt es auf GitHub, aber die kann kaum was von dem, was die aktuelle kann.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an, was die Must-Have-Features sind, wenn man einen Staubsauger-Roboter kauft.
Der macht übrigens auch ziemlich gute Videos, wenn es um das Thema Heimautomatisierung oder ein bisschen Gebastel geht. Nicht alles, beispielsweise will er den Leuten immer erzählen, dass es ja nicht schlimm ist, die Daten irgendwo in die China-Cloud zu legen und sowas. Da bin ich persönlich anderer Meinung zu, aber an sich sind die Videos echt nicht schlecht.
Also mal davon aussehen, ich kaufe mir jetzt nicht noch einen Staubsauger-Roboter, ich habe zwei und das reicht.
Scientific-Tests, Big-Brain-Time angesagt, Leute. Ja, zwei Stücke, ein Euphi 11 irgendwas, so ein ganz billiger, also von den Features billiger mit Infrarot-Fernbedienung und ein Show-Me, Show-Me heißt das übrigens, es heißt nicht Xiaomi, sondern es heißt Show-Me.
Roborock S50, geflasht natürlich, mit Custom-Firmware. Show-Me, Show-Me, ja, Show-Me, Show-Me. Aber ich merke es mir immer, dass man das wie Show-Me ausspricht, das ist ja ganz einfach.
Das Tool, das dir die Nachrichten auflistet, oh nee, das habe ich glaube ich nicht auf Github.
Ja, Sebaro habe ich, habe ich gesehen, mit AI.
Da ist er, den habe ich, den habe ich hier, den da.
Hat er Recht, hat er Recht.
Das lohnt sich wirklich.
Wie viel Aufwand ist es ein Staubsauger zu flaschen? Also der S50 ist ziemlich einfach, du brauchst einen Raspberry Pi für und du machst das anhand einer Anleitung.
Du machst das anhand einer Anleitung hier. Das ist die Custom-Firmware für den Staubsauger-Roboter und die haben hier eine Anleitung, die machst du einfach durch und dann hast du dein Staubsauger geflasht.
Ist relativ einfach, man darf aber nicht zu zimperlich sein.
Also wenn man sich nach jedem abgesetzten Kommando Gedanken macht, dauert das zu lange und wahrscheinlich verkackt man es auch irgendwie. Man muss einfach, einfach in your face, ja.
Auch mal ignorieren, wenn eine Fehlermeldung kommt, einfach weiter.
Wieso flasht man seinen Staubsauger, dass man zum Beispiel keine China Cloud mehr benutzen muss?
Einfach aufstehen und einen Schlüssel flüchten oder eine Karte holen.
Der Grund warum Robotic Vacuums so eine tolle Invention sind, ist, dass sie jemanden, der täglich sein Boden sauber machen sollte, und sie es tatsächlich tun.
Wenn du schon täglich dein Boden sauber machen möchtest, gut für dich. Du kannst dich aufhören.
Niemand, niemand der arbeiten geht, macht täglich seinen Boden sauber.
Ganz einfach habe ich gesehen, ich mache eigentlich so gut wie niemandem den Boden sauber, das ist eine der Gründe dafür.
Aber wenn du es nicht machst, wirst du überrascht, dass ein Robotic Vacuum dir die Qualität des Lebens erhöhen kann. Nicht nur werden deine Füße cleaner werden, aber du wirst weniger Dust auf deinem Furnitur, weniger Allergien im Luft, und indirekt...
Oder muss ich das Fiverr? Eigentlich wollte ich heute das Fiverr Video machen.
Das Video on stream, nee das geht nicht.
Das ist wirklich praktisch, also so wie man das jetzt hier sieht. So sieht das in dem Web Interface auch aus mit Customfirmen.
Das Schöne ist, dass die Customfirmen für den Staubsauger mittlerweile mehr kann, als die offizielle Firmen. Sieht im Prinzip genauso aus.
Ich habe euch ja meinen schon mal on stream gezeigt.
Lohnt sich das für eine Einzimmerwohnung? Ja, ich finde sogar dafür lohnt sich das.
Du stellst das Ding einfach so ein, dass das, also entweder hast du die Möglichkeit festzustellen, dass du es nicht machst.
Wenn du rausgehst, dass er dann anfängt, ohne du sagst zu einer gewissen Uhrzeit, wenn du immer nicht da bist.
Für eine Einzimmerwohnung kannst du dir allerdings auch nicht relativ, da ist es egal, ob der jetzt besonders clever den Raum reinigt oder den Raum abscant oder so vorher.
Da kannst du dir auch irgendwie so einen günstigen Euphi oder so kaufen für eine Einzimmerwohnung.
Aber wenn du so einen hier zum Beispiel günstig bekommst, finde ich lohnt sich das für eine Einzimmerwohnung.
Ich meine, eine Einzimmerwohnung ist ja immer eine Einzimmer, da ist auch ein Bad dabei, da ist wahrscheinlich auch eine Küche dabei.
Das sind ja eigentlich drei Zimmer und dafür lohnt sich das, finde ich.
Das Ding kann wischen, das Ding kann wischen, wobei ich benutze das Wischfeature nie.
Der S50 kann wischen und der hat auch einen Schutz dagegen, dass das Wasser ausläuft, falls er hängen bleibt.
Quake ist immer noch geil zu gucken.
4 zu 3 beste.
Das schöne ist, das schöne ist, dass Quake einen Replay Modus hatte.
Slipgate.
Slipgate